die ersten der 300.000 Reservisten die
Putin einziehen will sie ziehen jetzt in
den Krieg Abschied von ihren Familien so
sieht das aus Abschied vielleicht für
immer einige Experten sagen ja die
brutale Wahrheit sei das eben das sei
Putins Kanonenfutter schlecht oder nicht
ausgebildete Soldaten und die Familien
dieser Männer die Ahnen genau das in
diesen emotionalen Momenten Abschied in
den Krieg klar ist mit diesen Bildern
der ukraine-krieg ist jetzt in der
breiten Bevölkerung Russlands angekommen
plötzlich hunderttausende Familien die
mit diesem Krieg jetzt direkt zu tun
haben kippt da nun die Stimmung gegen
Putin in Russland Feld Putins Kartenhaus
zusammen
Demos sprechöre Verhaftungen diese
Bilder aus Russland belegen die von
Despot Putin angekündigte
thaimobilisierung rüttelt die Russen auf
sorgt für lautstärker Proteste 10.000
Menschen gehen auf die Straße und
besorgte Mütter rufen unsere Kinder
sollen leben
es gibt Medienberichte von russischen
Zeitungen die gehen davon aus dass bis
zu einer Million neuer Soldaten
mobilisiert werden soll das heißt diese
300.000 Mal wieder nur eine Lüge oder
nur die erste Welle erste Rekrutierungen
finden bereits statt ganz im Osten
Russlands weit weg von der Hauptstadt
Moskau und auch in Tschetschenien der
Provinz von Putins Blut und kadirov
bilden sich lange Schlangen mit teils
blutjungen unerfahrenen Rekruten auch
diese Bilder kursieren in den sozialen
Medien junge Russen die flüchten nicht
an der ukrainischen Front verheizt
werden möchten Ihre Angst durchaus
berechtigt genau
die Russen sind darauf nicht vorbereitet
ihnen Ausrüstung und Training zu geben
um sie vorbereitet für den Kampf in
Einheiten zu stecken es würde zwei oder
drei Monate dauern bis man mit einem
Effekt rechnen könnte die Ukraine wissen
jetzt dass sie eine Chance haben die
Sache zu beenden wir werden anhaltenden
Druck auf die Russen sehen
Putins Machtapparat gerät immer stärker
unter Druck wir sehen ja nicht nur
Demonstrationen wir sehen hier auch
erneut Massenflucht wir sehen wie sich
russische Männer an den Flughäfen
versammeln wir sehen lange Schlangen an
der Grenze zu Armenien deshalb all das
was gerade zusammenkommt das erhöht
natürlich die Gefahr für das
putin-regime und dann drohtina Mittwoch
erneut mit seinem Atomwaffenarsenal
möchte dem Westen damit Angst machen und
Panik verbreiten doch die Drohungen sie
sind wohl nichts als ein verzweifelter
Bluff bei Putin fällt auf dass er bei
seiner Atomwaffen Drohung erklärt hat
das ist kein Bluff
eigentlich heißt das eher das ist ein
blöd dann wenn man nicht läuft dann muss
man das nicht betonen er weiß aber dass
man ihm natürlich nicht glaubt deswegen
versucht er die Welt weiterhin davon zu
überzeugen gute ins Eskalation sie zeigt
also vor allem eines Verzweiflung sein
Kartenhaus der macht es wackelt
bedrohlich
[Applaus]
[Musik]